be specific not this mediocre generalist
the key to all of our issues is
love this keep stacking days as long as
you keep stacking days you will see the
change don't aim to be the best aim to
be the only the single most powerful
force for adolescent mental health is
strong relationships with caring adults
we through the spirit ual baby out with
the religious bath water you've got to
train and prime your brain to think of
Happiness like a practice like a habit
like something you invest in then being
happy leads to doing great work and the
great work leads to having big
success hey everybody greetings and
happy holidays from me and the entire
team of super talented people here at
the RRP
Studio as the year comes to an end and
we like to close things out here with a
little bit of a gratitude check a
celebration with this annual tradition
that we started many years ago the best
of series and this year 2023 is going to
be a two-part compilation of the most
enlightening excerpts from the previous
12 months of the show 2023 was just
packed with this astonishing array of
guests we learned from scientists and
doctors conducting Cutting Edge research
in the field of nutrition long ity
disease prevention and more creative
Masters Shar the wisdom behind their
craft athletes reported back from the
outer edges of human capability and
individuals who experienced phoenix-like
Transformations gave us actionable
advice on just what it really takes to
truly change your life wholesale for all
of you devoted podcast fans out there I
think you should think of these next two
episodes as a bit of a recap kind of a
way to remind yourself of your favorite
lessons from your favorite guests and
for those newer to the show perhaps
consider this as kind of a spark notes
or a cliffnotes version of the show a
bit of a crash course to entice you to
mine through the catalog and dial up
episodes you may have missed or perhaps
skipped and with that I'm excited to
share these Premier Clips with you
starting with the great and wise Seth
Goen Seth is not only the author of 19
best-selling books he's also a leading
Authority on on all kinds of subjects
everything from creativity to marketing
who has also been writing every single
day since 2005 here's some wisdom on how
to stay committed to your craft and be
the best at what you
do if you are a pizza lover and you
think about the great pizza places in
the United States none of them are full
service restaurants with big menus they
make a thing and they make it the best
they can make it because it must be done
with care or it becomes
mediocre and we have created an entire
generation of wandering generalities as
zigs would say instead of meaningful
specifics and to be a meaningful
specific you have to say this is what I
do you can't say and and and and and
because then you have an excuse for
everything being sort of average and if
your slogan is you can pick anyone and
we're anyone then someone else is going
to win you want to be in and of yourself
the one and only version of that
so I think that's a universal law I
think that if somebody is more focused
than you they're going to put in more
Cycles than you and they're going to
learn more than you and inevitably
they're going to become better than you
when you have enough competitors so with
that said you got to say well the only
way that's going to happen is if I say
no to all sorts of attractive things so
in my case as somebody who has a certain
kind of willpower it means uh no Twitter
No Instagram no Facebook Facebook no
LinkedIn uh almost no travel there are
all these things I don't do because I
don't want to reconsider every time
because it would be a huge number of
Cycles to say oh that but this one's
really special I should open the door
and think about that one again but is
this a function of not wanting to fall
into the kind of uh pleasure trap of
scrolling or is it because you don't
want to be influenced by what other
people are saying or their reaction I'm
not reading them but I'm also not
writing on those platforms so when
Twitter came along it was the early days
I saw it I said I could probably have a
lot of people following me on Twitter
yeah but if I got good at Twitter I
would have to become mediocre at
blogging so I don't want to do that I
want to be really good at the thing I do
and not do the other thing so that's
part A and yes as you pointed out
listening to Anonymous trolls makes
nobody better I've never met an author
who said I read all my onear reviews on
Amazon and now I'm a better right WR so
11 years ago I stopped reading my
reviews on Amazon I haven't read a
review Once since that day cuz I'm not
going to learn anything from a onear
review other than it wasn't for me well
you just told me about you but you
didn't tell me about my work so I get it
it wasn't for you but that's not what I
need to learn to get better I think many
people fall into this illusion that
whatever they're creating is for
everybody and they don't have that
Clarity around who specifically they
writing for creating for and as a result
the work suffers right and this is
something this is a drum you've been
beating you know from the beginning
about you know all the way back to
tribes Etc um about like having that
definitive sense of who you're serving
and I think we're in an interesting time
now because the internet has fractured
the monoculture and everything is about
tribes now there is it's very unlikely
that we're going to see you know only
rarely now do we see gigantic creative
offerings that move the entire culture
yes and because of that it's created
opportunity for many people but I feel
like people still fall under the
delusion that they need to be like
Taylor Swift or George Lucas or somebody
like
that Taylor Swift this is I got of the
fact that like yeah I got to interrupt
you this is such an easy thing to descri
and a hard thing to embrace so about 7
mil from here is a 4 Mile Trail where
you can go in a state park into the
woods and find out where they filmed
Mash like you're in the DM my backyard
Trail it's a real I was there yesterday
and I took pictures and sent them back
to the family and my wife's like that's
really cool and the kids's like what's
this so Mash was the most popular TV
show ever broadcast when it went off the
year the last episode 70 million plus
people saw so to compare 70 million
people to a show like The Sopranos or
Mad Men or whatever which got seen by
three million people when they were
broadcast right 120th the number or if
you think about anything that your
friends people in quotation marks are
talking about on Netflix a million two
million people are seeing it when it's
first coming out what it means to win on
the long tail is you're a tiny drip in a
giant [__] it and that's enough so I've
had 20 bestsellers in a row and not one
of them has sold to more than 1% of the
US population which means that 99% of
the US population said nah not
interested no idea who you are see you
that's not failure that's success so
writing for all these people who are
never going to engage with you making a
TV show or a podcast for
everyone no don't don't make cereal
because cereal ends up being popular cuz
something had to win that day's Lottery
but it's probably not going to be you no
and it's very specific in what it is I
don't I I don't think anybody involved
in that program anticipated the success
nor were they making it for the purpose
of impacting culture on a mass level
right but if you copy them and say well
this is going to be the next blank
you've lost why you're doing it the
thread you're saying someone's going to
Wi the lottery it's going to be me and
we see struggling people struggling with
income tricked into buying lottery
tickets for that very reason and it's a
dumb investment and instead put
ourselves on the hook and say no I'm
making this for you know the vegan
community of Agora Hills California and
if they don't like it I have failed
because it's for them and that's who
it's for so I put myself on the hook
when I say that whereas if I say I'm
making the best thing I can and
hopefully lots of people will like it
well then when a few people don't like
it you can just say well I'm waiting for
the next people I'm waiting for lucky
break how do I hype this and so putting
yourself on the hook that's how you get
funding for your project that's how you
hire people that's how you get a job be
specific not this average mediocre
generalist from going plant-based in her
40s to starting a restaurant in her 50s
Chef babet Davis is a Living testament
to all late bloomers that it's never too
late to change at 72 years young she is
the absolute bottle of fit ripped and
absolutely radiant and here is an
excerpt lifted from episode 731 one of
the most viral episodes of the
year it's very important to be now to
take responsibility for myself and my
feelings no ma no matter what I I I I
take responsibility for those things in
particular but it wasn't always like
that I did a lot of finger pointing and
if it wasn't for for you and if it
hadn't been for that and if I would you
know what I'm saying the victim the vi
the victim and um it's it it doesn't
really serve me in my life to to be the
victim I don't need to hold grudges I
take responsibility for me and I just
think it's important for each and every
one of us to do that and to understand
that they're all learning experiences I
I just appreciate this human Journey so
very much because from whence I came to
where I am now and my voice being bigger
and bigger I would have never thought
anybody would ever even listen to me but
to now share that Human Experience and
embrace love that is the key to all of
our issues is love it really is I can't
say it enough yeah you understand when
each of us takes on the
responsibility of embracing love and
understanding that there is no
separation it's like I am just an
expression of my
Creator period it's like I can't make
that amazing mac and cheese I met made
today before I left the restaurant
without it being also an expression of
me yeah and so I know that I believe I
was created in and of this power of love
and so I feel better in that space than
I do anywhere else what really um
impacts people the most is when they see
somebody who is a living example of a
certain lifestyle and they're doing it
in a way that is is aspirational but
still like you know not so far out there
that they can't see themselves in that
person and I feel like you serve that
role beautifully in many categories I
mean first of all somebody who's been
eating you know an organic plant-based
diet and I don't know probably
predominantly raw for like 30 years
right now you're you're on the cusp of
turning 72 you're like I said earlier
you're just you're radiating positivity
your skin is insane like you I mean I
it's it's crazy that you're 72 like you
just you look like I don't know you look
like you're 36 or something and you're
totally jacked you got like veins coming
out of your arm you can do push-ups all
day and on Instagram you're sharing
these videos of you doing your exercise
routine and it's very inspiring and it's
very empowering like reframing how we
think about aging and having this
conversation around longevity and the
relationship between the choices that we
make the things we put in our body the
the choices we make about how we
interact with other people like it's
more than just oh here's a salad it's
about that self-love piece it's about
exuding love it's about like how are you
being of service how are you
contributing all of these things that
you're about without being preachy
you're just an example and they say you
know I know for myself even it really
helps you rethink about what our
relationship is to getting older and
what that means the beauty of it the
beauty of the aging process and after
that's this entire journey to be able to
say that I'm 72 and enjoy each and every
moment of um my time on this planet in
this form um it's just amazing and I'm
so grateful to life I really am I'm so
grateful to have this opportunity to do
what it is that I do and love it so much
um wow you said a mouthful
let's let's walk through the fitness
routine I want to know first of all you
don't sleep we can talk about that like
I read that you get up at like 2:30 in
the morning but I go to B about that I
go to bed at 6 rich I go to bed at 6
come on they left that part out I get
plenty of rest trust I'm very very still
and quiet at home most of the time I'm
I'm to myself I live alone I enjoy that
um um to be able to share that and let
people know that man part of part of the
whole self-loving thing is to be a part
of all of this to be able to move you
know if if if I want to run a hill I can
run a hill I don't want to have a Life
Alert I don't I don't want to get in the
bathtub and can't get out uh so I force
myself to take bath sometimes I'm not
always taking showers make sure you get
your butt out the tub uh yeah
but that's the whole thing when you get
older it's all about like if you fall
down and you can't get up you can't get
that's what people need to really
understand now of course sometimes we
have accidents that you know is not any
fault of our own but uh when we just sit
down and just let it go that's generally
what will happen to you you lose
strength and another thing that I I I
think is I'm not a superficial person I
um I enjoy the aging process I don't
look like I looked when I was 60 you
know what I mean but however it is
however this look is going to be as I
age I embrace it because just think I've
lived an entire lifetime looking
different so you know what I mean it's
not a bad thing to have the the crow's
feet I I don't I don't care to use
anything to get rid of that I'm okay
with it I I want to see what what it's
going to be I saw one of the most
beautiful women I've ever seen before
she we lines like in this table but she
was
beautiful she was beautiful and if just
to exp she owned it and she's
comfortable with who she is and oh she
was just gorgeous and that is how we
should all be because it's each step of
the journey that we
Embrace and appreciate
mhm what role does does emotional health
play in longevity well physician
engineer and Stanford Medical School
grad Peter Atia MD return to the podcast
to answer this question and much more in
episode 743 which is this really
powerful primer on the role of trauma
and it's untangling and how that plays
into both well-being and
[Music]
Longevity one of the things that I never
thought could go away I talk about this
in the book is the whole Bobby Knight
thing this was one of the most important
realizations I ever had when I was at
PCS which is my what my inner monologue
sounded
like and it
sounds well it's a little hard to
believe I wasn't aware of it given that
it wasn't just an inner monologue it was
actually also an outer
monologue I would constantly say things
to myself out loud whenever I made
mistakes the selft talk was not just in
my head it was it was verbal it would it
would come out mhm and it was awful
right it
was the re the reason I called that
Bobby Knight is that's that's who it was
modeled after right it was coach Knight
is going to strangle you if you make a
mistake and it was anything right it
didn't matter if I screwed up making
dinner if I screwed up a shot if I
screwed up anything if I was late to a
call I remember one morning I woke up
and there was a call on my calendar at
600 that I had forgot about and I when I
woke up I did a whole bunch of other
things before and I missed the call I
mean instead of just emailing ing the
person and saying hey I'm really sorry I
mean I must have beat myself up about
that for a day
uhhuh and this exercise that they had me
do there was one of the most powerful
things I've ever done and when they
suggested it I
thought that seems kind of dumb like
there's no way that's going to work and
they were like every single day two or
three times something is going to happen
that's going to prompt you to want to
scream at yourself take out your phone
and record a message but look into the
eyes of your best friend and pretend
that they made that mistake what would
you say to
them I mean the first few times I did
this I was in
tears because it was such a shift of how
kind I would speak to that
person you know hey Peter I know it's
frustrating you you just you know didn't
have a good drive today but you know I
think I think there's a lot on your mind
today and and you know you did okay but
you know you got to watch the Apex going
into this corner and like I literally I
was like talking like I was a a kind
coach yeah and there was an
accountability where every one of those
I would send to my therapist she'd get
like two or three of these voice
messages a day for four
months and it only took about four
months for that to go
away that is really amazing to me yeah
that's powerful think of how old I am
and think of how many years I had this
ingrain
pattern of screaming at myself and I
mean I don't even want to repeat the
stuff I say CU it's so vile but like
it's not like you idiot no no it's much
harsher than that and in Just 4 months
of being mindful of this every single
day I don't even REM I it's so hard for
me to remember Bobby's voice it's pretty
unusual for someone who's out of shape
to not know they're out of shape right
you know if you if you're having a hard
time walking up a hill if you're having
a hard time climbing stairs if it if it
hurts when you get out of bed in the
morning it's hard to not know
that it's really easy to be emotionally
broken and not fully appreciate it or or
more to the point to be like me and be
in total
denial I think the single most important
thing a person has to do here is if for
no other reason and to no one other than
themselves start asking questions
like are
you are you living in a way where your
relationships with other people are
healthy what what what was modeled to
you what what did you see and if you go
back and reflect on
that do you think that that represents
the best version of how you know people
can
interact um there are lots of tests
people can take for example you're
probably familiar with the adverse
childhood event score the ace score mhm
this is something that's readily
available online I do recommend people
take it right if you're if you're sort
of sitting there thinking like I don't
know what trauma is well this is a
checklist of 10 things some of which are
really obvious like you know you're
raped that's trauma um but your parents
going through a divorce when you're a
kid is trauma right um so you know when
you kind of go through an inventory like
that it at least gives you some sense of
vulnerability I think that we talk about
this a little bit that it's a little
harder for men to do
this
but whether you're male or female I
think you've you've got to ask yourself
the question do you have someone you can
really confide in like do you have a
friend that you could tell anything to
you know or what there's a a test for it
they call like do you have someone you
could call in the middle of the night if
something was wrong mhm if you can't
answer yes to that
question I wonder why right is it
because you don't feel comfortable that
you can share that or is it because you
really don't have that person in your
life I I think everybody benefits from
Psychotherapy and I don't think it's
very sexy what's very sexy today what's
very invogue today is like psychedelics
right like M you know all you need
is a trip to Peru with a shaman and
everything's going to be
fixed and I talk very briefly about this
in the book but I've had most of these
experiences and some of them have
actually been very
positive but they aren't the healing
process they are just disruptive right
they just disrupt your psyche enough
that they make you open to the change
the the change has to come from finding
a therapist in my view who you are
comfortable enough to be able to speak
with and I think it's rather agnostic to
the specialty your
discipline um I the important thing is
that you are engaging with some modality
from a place of openness and honesty
yeah and it's just as we would say look
you got to go get a blood test you got
to go get this test done you got to go
do these certain things like you should
know your V2 Max you should know your
you know your bone mineral density you
should have a dexa scan I I think we
should take the same approach here which
is you should be able to have someone
that you emotionally check in with and
someone who can ask you questions and
get you thinking and and provoke you a
little bit and figure out what your
state of emotional health
is this year marked the return of one of
my favorite teen Whisperers Dr Lisa
deore a Yale educated psychotherapist
and best-selling author of the emotional
lives of teenagers Lisa joined me to
decode today's teens and uh they most
pressing
issues when kids come our way to tell us
they are upset which they often do
teenagers especially talkers are good at
this overwhelmingly all they want and
all they need is for us to listen and be
empathic in response for us to really
tune in the way I I try to do this as a
parent is if one of my daughters is
telling me she's upset about something
I'll picture she's a repor and I'm her
editor and she's reading me the article
of her distress and that when she gets
to the end of the article I just have to
produce the headline like I have to have
listened so intently that I can distill
it and summarize it and add nothing and
give it back to her so really all they
want is that level of listening and then
truly rich like the number one thing I
say in my home more than anything is
like oh man that stinks right just just
sitting and empathizing in
response that is overwhelmingly what
teenagers are looking for and so often
and I do this too what they get instead
is advice like they tell us what's wrong
and we're like well you know and
um I one of my younger daughter said to
me she said Mom I can tell from the look
on your face when I'm talking to you
when you stopped listening you've come
up with the thing you're going to say to
me by way of advice and you're now just
waiting for me to pause right right
you're just like okay let me just wait
until this is over and then I'm going to
I'm going to throw the Zinger drop some
wisdom on you so so what I would say is
it's very rarely what they're looking
for or what they want or need and it
usually actually um ruins a moment that
could be going quite a bit better so
curiosity plus empathy or just empathy
is I would say overwhelmingly the most
effective and also wanted response when
teenagers come our way with their
distress one thing I was so delighted to
discover in writing this book is
something that was happening in my home
and that I think a lot of families think
is just happening in their home is that
the kid who tells them nothing after
school at dinner asking great questions
parents getting nothing Waits until the
parent is in bed and then is suddenly
standing there as chatty as can be M and
when I realized this was like near
Universal like this was happening in so
many homes I thought okay well this is
fascinating and what I think is
happening is the
teenager is satisfying two needs at once
they want to be autonomous but they want
to connect with the parent and so if
they wait till we're in bed they decide
if there's going to be a meeting they
decide the content of the meeting cuz
they know we're not going to bring up
new topics at that time and they decide
when it ends so what I would say is
maybe your kid's not a nighttime talker
but I have become increasingly aware
there are kids who don't want to talk
when the parent wants to talk but they
will text with the parent or they will
have conversations in the car that they
need a lot of tight control over the
conversation in order to have it
the other scenario that comes up is that
the teenager doesn't want to talk
because they the parent stepped in it
the parent did something when they did
talk that made the kid uncomfortable
about opening up and when I've asked
teenagers like you know you know that
thing where you're clearly upset and
your parents asking what's wrong and you
know you're just shaking them off
shaking them off they're like yeah yeah
yeah I'm like what what's the deal like
what's the deal and they're like well
there's a few different reasons so the
reasons they give me they say well
sometimes it's because we know what
you're going to say so I'm upset because
I messed up my math test and it's the
math test that you asked me if I was
ready for and I told you I was but it
turns out I was not and so if I if I
tell you that that's the issue I'm going
to basically get an I told you so and I
don't want to hear it so I can't tell
you another reason they'll give me is
they'll say you're going to blab right
so I'm going to tell you about something
that's Happ happening for me or a friend
and then the next thing I know you're
going to be on the horn either with the
school or with the neighbor or with your
sister and I did not mean for this to
leave the house and so I'm not telling
you
stuff um and then I thought this was so
beautiful I girl said to me here's the
deal by the time I get home I am 90% of
the way over whatever I was upset about
and rehashing the whole thing from my
parents is not going to help me feel
better so I think we sometimes want to
be attentive that like they know us they
we may have stepped in it and if we have
we have to apologize and try to you know
repair that and I think teenagers can be
pretty forgiving you know if you're
earnestly apologetic I think you can
open channels of
communication there's so much in that
yeah I mean all allowing the the teen to
set the parameters for these types of
discussions not trying to force them
trying to uh refrain from judgment or
you know stepping into the you know on
these landmines that are are typically
the things that that cut off
communication right uh resisting the
urge to try to solve the problem or step
in and intervene or like tell some story
about what happened to you when they you
were that age which is like the worst
right want to end a conversation I would
say that's the last thing they want to
hear right when I was a teenager is like
the most conversation ending thing you
can possibly say as a parent when I was
a teenager I know um I mean I've just
learned cuz we have a quieter child and
and it it's funny cuz just the other
night like that exact thing happened
like right when I was going to bed you
know
um and you have to just like you live
for those moments because you can't
compel them so you have to like be in a
place of of sort of surrender around it
and then when they happen you you have
to have the you like have to have the
awareness like oh okay it's h I have to
I have to turn on now because this is a
fleeting thing you know doesn't happen
that often it requires a lot of patience
it does it really really does so here's
how I think we summon that patience
first of all this is really short-lived
and and one of the things I'm so glad
about is that I was practicing before I
had kids and I had so many people I was
caring for so many parents say oh my
gosh it goes so fast like they're out so
fast because my personality is a bit
more on the controlling side and I know
that if I didn't have that professional
reminder all of the time of how
shortlived this would be I know I would
have been like clean up your shoes
they're in the wrong place and let me go
to sleep I mean I know I would have
demanded more in that way and so um and
now I have a kid in college right and
and it's true and so for me in those
moments where I'm like oh really right
now I think you know what in three years
I would give my left arm to have you
come to talk to me right like I'm not
going to know where you are at 11
o'clock at night so I think that helps
and then the other thing I think is more
important than it's ever been is that
the single most powerful force for
adolescent mental health is strong
relationships with caring adults so we
have to meet them more than halfway we
just have
to don't go anywhere we got a lot more
on the horizon but first a quick word
from the partners who make the show
possible
globally renowned epidemiologist
geneticist and co-founder of the data
science company Zoe Tim Spectre dropped
by the studio to bust diet Miss share
the importance of plant diversity in
one's diet and teach us how to optimize
our microbiome for whole body
Health in general terms the microbiome
is the term we use for the community of
microbes microorganisms that live in our
bodies and we generally refer to the 99%
that live in our lower intestine our
colon and the microbiome really refers
to the genes of those microbes um should
technically be called the
microbiota but we just use the most
microbiome because I'm not fussy about
words and um everyone now understands
that so these
there some dispute about how many there
are but they're probably there're
certainly TR I may 100 trillion or so
roughly the same numbers of cells in our
body most of them are the ones we know
about are bacteria but there also these
other related species called ARA and
there are fungi and uh yeasts and there
are viruses five times as many viruses
as bacteria that feed off them called
fages which also have a role in health
and there are even parasites that
virtually all of us have to some extent
in our guts and some of which turn out
to be beneficial as well so it's this
whole Community a bit like an ecosystem
that is living within us and it best
consider a virtual organ stick them all
together they weigh about 2 kilograms
same as your brain and they're basically
as I said these mini pharmacies pumping
out chemicals which send signals all
over a body but particularly to all the
immune cells the majority of which our
immune cells are actually lining our gut
and so they interact with those immune
cells on a constant basis signaling
whether to uh be aggressive or be
passive and modifying them tuning them
up and down that helps fight aging helps
fight cancer sorts out allergies um etc
etc infect fights infections and they
also produce lots of chemicals that
might go to our brain um responsible for
serotonins and um many other Pathways in
the brain as well so affects our mood
and obviously our metabolism and how we
digest food amongst others and there
right like so many things infinite
things if there are any kind of concrete
you know rules or or recommendations for
the person who's you know brand new to
the idea of the microbiome even being a
thing and who's grappling with the idea
of making you know healthier choices for
themselves um you know beyond the 30
kind of plants of week uh what are some
other principles uh top of mind you know
what sits a top the kind of most
important of those well we've covered
some of them so obviously eating the
rainbow is you know the colors are there
for a reason and they're actually really
good so you know don't eat beige yeah
don't eat beige yeah go colorful um
that's the that's the title of this
podcast go bitter many bitter things are
actually good um you know one reason
coffe is so healthy for you is it's got
full of polyphenols and you know
recommend coffee over orange juice
anytime as a health drink should be in
the health
section uh dark chocolate's another
surprising one cook cook with extra
virgin olive oil rather than any other
oil don't believe all this nonsense
about um heat heating points yes stuff
that's all rubbish um the um the way you
eat is also important so um we you know
we've we've talked um about what to eat
but uh time restriction eating we've
discussed we didn't discuss that
actually has a really big benefit on
your gut microbes so all the studies
show that if you leave a big gap um
overnight so your your gut is rested
just as the hunter gatherer tribes did
you know they they're not nibbling uh
snack bars or protein bars at night they
you know they're resting just as they're
sleeping giving that full Cadian Rhythm
real chance to real synchronize so I
think that's that's an important part so
there reducing the snacking time less
meals giving yourself you know at least
12 hours overnight ideally 14 is a good
way for your gut to to repair itself and
enhance um eating more
slowly um we all eat too fast I think
one five American meals are consumed in
the car you know it's difficult to have
a leisurely meal in the car
um just you know wait do like the
Mediterranean countries you know just
don't have snacks wait and have a proper
meal you know make it a social good
occasion enjoy the food um and uh you
know learn to try something new every uh
every week you should be aiming
something something new as extra so part
of this 30 plants is to discover new
things you haven't eaten and you know
get your taste buds to try something
something new all the time and introduce
that to your family and make make food
something exciting rather than a chore
because we all get into these ruts in
our choices we find something we like
and we think it's healthy we have the
same thing well that you know our
microbes don't like that we you know
they like to be tested all the time so I
think it's all about an adventure
experimenting find out whether you're
someone who does well you know with this
long overnight fast and not snacking or
whether you are someone who does need to
eat there are different people are you
an early morning person a late morning
person try skipping breakfast try
changing your breakfast for you know
from a high carb one to a high fat one
see how you feel try and just think
about how your body's working don't
accept that everything's the same for
everybody and I think the more we can
all experiment and and understand our
bodies the better we get to understand
food and and live with it and and always
think about your food now again in these
food choices if you care about the
planet really think about th those those
food choices you're making because as an
individual it is the number one thing we
can all do uh to save our planet and I
think it's not about you know that one
thing that you do or you don't do it's
about the holistic view of that what can
you get on your plate clearly if you got
a
you know if 3/4 of it filled with a
giant steak there's not much room for
your plants right so the top level rule
just being 30 plants a week and
diversity of plant life in your diet on
a the most consistent basis possible is
producing the diversity in that gut
microbiome ecology that is going to be
you know the sort of front lines of
keeping you healthy yeah and it's it's
it's a nice simple rule that means you
don't have to be too strict about right
anything else because if that's your
number one rule then everything you know
follow yes it's nice to have you know
the rich colorful polyphenol rich foods
it's nice you know the fermented foods
are we know are good as well avoiding
ultr processed foods uh Etc but that to
me is still number one and I think
that's been a a
good you know
a really good way of communicating it
also to the public about understanding
why you want to feed your gut why feed
your gut microbes you do it by eating
right for anyone in any creative Pursuit
weathering rejection is one of the most
difficult parts of making your dream
manifest so here to give us guidance on
how to build creative tenacity is writer
actor and director Zoe liser Jones who
joined me this year to talk talk about
the creative process behind her newest
binge worthy comedy
slip when you look at like Stu the
studio system there's such an attention
to um creating something for Mass
audience and I think what's misguided
about the process a lot of the time is
that the idea is that you're supposed to
water it down and when you see some a
company like a24 who instead is
sharpening The Singularity of a vision
and that's what's actually speaking to
such Mass audiences like what a great
lesson I also think like making
something with an audience in mind to me
is always sort of like the death now you
know like make something that you want
to like what is the story you want to
tell and that's what you put out into
the world because when you start to be I
think product oriented over process
oriented
Ed yeah it can get you into some trouble
and yet it is a business and you know
there are people sitting around
conference room tables trying to figure
out if it's going to work in China or
it's going to work in this other place
and those are the things that dictate
budgets yeah I mean when I say it's like
figure out what story you want to write
if if I was if I was talking to like a
filmmaker I would say figure out what
story you want to write what story you
have to
write um and then think about a way to
make it cheaply you know like I'm not
taking business out of the equation
because I think you do have to be
pragmatic if you if you're a first-time
filmmaker and you write some huge epic
it's never going to get made and that
might be the story you think you need to
tell but what's if you distilled that
story down what's the contained version
of it and then go you know figure out a
way to make that
because uh every single project I've
ever made has had 1,000 nose before
there's been anyes so how do you like
weather the
rejection because you're in a business
you're you you've become very successful
in this business but it's a business of
like you said you know mostly knows yeah
and being able to kind of like hold true
to yourself and and what you're doing
and not you know get overly dissuaded by
that I guess it come I it comes back to
confidence which is hard right like cuz
nose
will uh diminish your
confidence I've always had
something where I don't believe them it
doesn't mean that I it doesn't mean that
I don't take notes right like if if
someone says no I have to look at what
they're saying no to and what I can
shift but
um it requires such tenacity to keep
going and that tenacity is ultimately
like an unwavering sense of self or a
sense
that you have something that deserves a
voice um and I don't
know I don't know how how how to
cultivate that necessarily except for to
just keep going I think you just have to
keep going I think making your own work
is really important like darl and I made
work in the face of 1,000 NOS by just
going and doing it
ourselves and you know that's a real
stress test of the work yeah I feel like
um just in looking at like the projects
that you guys did together you it feels
like you just pulled this [__] out of
your ass like you're like well we're
going to go make this movie and you're
I'm like what and then like somehow
you're like out in the street like
shooting like you just
you progress as if like even if all the
pieces aren't together like you're just
in motion moving forward and you know
when you create that momentum somehow
everything else you know those other
problems that seem insurmountable start
to get
resolved yeah yeah I mean you know it's
like manifesting I guess 101 is
like I am doing it you can tell me no
and I can take a note and shift
something you can tell me know and say
well we have something else like it
which is what you're always hearing or
you know like and it's like well but do
you and can't there be many things that
are in the same world but have different
voices behind them and
um I guess the best advice I ever was
given uh was by a producer named Alex
Madigan who took me to coffee and said
you should direct and I didn't know that
and it's like a wild simple piece of
advice but I think that it does
take sometimes I think it for many
people but especially for women and
especially for women in film
like this sense of confidence even if
you don't know if you haven't gone to
film school if you don't have every
answer you don't know every lens you
know that someone saw that and
said go do it you got it mhm and that's
really all it took to have that outside
external voice see something in you that
maybe you're not ready to see in
yourself yeah um even when I was in high
school and I was acting I I was in the
chorus of a musical I had no confidence
as an actor and some like parent in the
PTA was like you're really good you're
the one I'm watching in the background
and and so I guess tell people when you
think they're talented because it's
really meaningful and it's a really hard
World across all
Industries and those are are really
character building moments in terms of
giving
someone yeah a sense of value in in the
craft they might be interested in but
too afraid to
pursue everyone wants to be happy but
why does it feel so complicated well
here to simplify and clarify our
happiness equation is the author of a
ser Ser of books on all things awesome
my friend Neil Pasa who just delivered
this amazing powerful primer on how to
build a life of purpose how to cultivate
fulfillment and allocate your time here
on Earth more intentionally here's a
piece so just zooming out like a huge
level before we get into like my My
Views let's just remember that 2400
years ago in ancient Athens Aristotle at
the world's first University Plato's
Republic had a very famous quote
happiness is the meaning and purpose of
life the whole aim and end of human
existence that if you want to talk about
people that have made a career out of
happiness or or you know there's the OG
guy right the original happiness
influencer well before that it was like
survival like we got we just got to make
it through this thing you know like he's
like no no no no no no no the whole
purpose is also we got to enjoy it too
2400 years ago he they put that down
right then Flash Forward 2,000 years
they write the Declaration of
Independence you know the famous phrase
they put in there everybody gets life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness but
you're a lawyer Rich you know it's the
legal EAS in there you don't get
happiness you get to pursue it you get
to pursue it you get the pursuit of it
life liberty you get those for sure but
happiness you just get to chase it right
so now we Flash Forward all the way up
to 1998 let's say Martin cman and mial
chicks at miay are co-founders of a new
a new field that they they invent called
positive psychology right and for a lot
of your listeners who have heard that
phrase before positive psychology it's
we should remember it that phrase didn't
exist in our culture before 25 years ago
so that's still a relatively new phrase
so from 1998 to to today hundreds and
hundreds of Studies have been done
applying the scientific model to the
study of Happiness right Carol D on
growth mindset Slater and Panabaker on
on journaling emmen Mulla on gratitude s
laamiri at University of California
there's these there's these there's this
massive huge emerging body of work and
literature so I just use those three
points to just say like just let look
what's happened here like 2000 we say
this is important then we write it into
the the Declaration we got to chase it
and now we're like starting to actually
study it only really 25 years ago now I
think that the underpinning of how we
think about happiness in our society is
totally backwards okay we when I was a
kid what my parents said to me was we've
already talked about this a few times
but it's like come on you know St study
hard you know get get straight A and you
go be a doctor the model therefore is
great work leads to big success leads to
be happy right and that model is also if
you're listening to this and you're a
parent it's like don't you say to your
own K come on we want you to get into a
good school come on we want you to get a
good job come on we just want you to be
that's common parental wisdom and it's
totally false so after coming through
all studies there's a really formative
study done by sonki with Ed Diner and K
uh King Jane King and they show that
actually that model's totally backwards
it's not great work big success be happy
it's the opposite it's you got to train
your brain to be happy
first then if you can do that if you can
think of Happiness like a practice like
a habit like something you can invest in
you invest in your physical health so
beautifully we see that we aspire to it
we see that you're a model but how many
people do you look around and you see
them investing in their happiness the
same way we don't we aren't as a culture
doing this yet then the great work
follows happy people are 31% more
productive they have 37% higher sales
they're 300% more creative you can go
down the ly of all kinds of things that
happy people show up better they're more
connected and then the big success comes
at the end what kind of success two
kinds if you want to go on the career
point which I was on for a second there
happy people are 40% more likely to get
a promotion in the next 12 months but
just zooming up a level there's this
really famous study called the nun study
that shows you know what happy people Al
also live live longer and if going back
to our earlier conversation you only got
30,000 days here well if I told you if
you you could get 3,000 more mhm bowls
of ice cream kissing your kids good
night watching the sunset running on the
trails behind this place would you do it
so again it's not great work big success
be happy it's the reverse you've got to
train and prime your brain to think of
happiness like a practice like a habit
like something you invest in then being
happy leads to doing great work and the
great work leads to having big success
and and on top of all that a lot of the
practices that turns out that do help
you cultivate happiness have got real
bad ad campaigns they don't have uh the
benefit of anyone advertising trees no
one's advertising trees right now well
because you can't profit from it that's
exactly what I'm saying that's exactly
what I'm saying the vast majority of
things that I'm about to tell you about
that can actually IMB our lives with a
bit more happiness they don't have great
Giant ad campaigns and we aren't talking
about them and in a in the what our
culture is trying to teach us is that
you got to buy more stuff you got to
click more links you got to buy more
things and that path to happiness is you
know whatever is on a billboard that
looks that looks pretty that you know
someone smiling that implicit things
that that's going to lead to happiness
it's not zooming up a level
look you're a paragon of this rich but
like like just getting outside and being
in nature and by the way I'll just
preface this point uh by saying we we
have the lowest ever levels of nature
exposure in our children in history
according to the American time you study
7% of a kid's day right now is spent
outside 7% well do the math multiply 7%
by seven days in the week that's 49% it
takes a kid a whole week to get half a
day outside now right so what's the
solution Michael babic and a team of
research have shown that even three 30
minute exercise or outdoor Windows a
week ultimately results in higher
happiness levels than people taking
anti-depressants or people doing both
they compared it to a a subgroup doing
both the the walking and taking the
anti-depressants so this this I said
trees have a bad ad campaign it's like
we're missing the amount that we really
need to be outside and the one of the
biggest ways I tell people to do this is
if you have a meeting on your calendar
with someone you know that you like
already that you trust already whether
it's your boss whether it's your direct
report whether it's a weekly meeting
that you always have just say to the
person let's both do it outside let's
just both do it outside the average
person walks six kilometers an hour you
move one hour meeting a week outside you
get sixk of of walking move two you got
12 move three you got 18 it's a simple
way to just introduce a little bit more
outdoor activity in your life doesn't
cost anything and it has a huge positive
disproportion effect on your happiness
how do we access our intuition how do we
make decisions from a place of inner
peace and how do we become more
integrated and healed humans answering
these important questions is the life's
work of Dr Richard Schwarz author of no
bad parts and creator of something
called internal family systems or ifs
here's a glimpse into our powerful
exchange what is is internal family
systems ifs set the stage and and and
explain your perspective um on your
particular modality of treating people
okay uh what it is it it began as a form
of psychotherapy and it's kind of
expanded to being more like a life
practice or a way of understanding human
beings that's a bit of a different
Paradigm and uh
you the basic assumption is none of us
are unitary personalities that it's the
nature of the mind to have lots of
different what I call Parts but other
people call other names ego States
things like that subers
personalities that it's natural and that
those
parts uh are all
valuable so I wrote a book no bad parts
I've been doing this 40 years mhm and
I've done it with people done heinous
things and even those parts if you
listen to their secret history will
reveal how they're just stuck in a place
in the past and they trying to best
protect the person and they carry this
energy of their perpetrator and so on so
in that sense it's quite a radical shift
in Paradigm right given that the
conventional traditional uh
psychological Paradigm is one of
monomind as opposed to this multip
licity of Minds that is kind of the the
pathway into understanding your
perspective yeah and uh when I started
talking about multiplicity the big
Paradigm was from what's now called the
did uh literature which would be
multiple personality disorder
originally and they would acknowledge
the existence of these what they called
altars but it was thought that they were
fragments of the broken vase that you
were initially unitary and then trauma
produced all these fragmented
personalities that took on a life of
their own and uh so I've been fighting
that Paradigm for a long time too cuz
for me they pre-existed the trauma and
then they got into extreme roles because
of the
trauma sometimes just because they were
trying their best to keep you safe when
you were young when it
happened but um they they exist they're
they're real it's not the the product of
the trauma so in other words there are
there is this I guess for lack of a
better word immutable there's an
immutable self and ancillary to that
immutable self are all of these parts
that are swimming around and they're
they're in relationship with each other
and they're they're performing various
roles depending upon things that happen
to you Etc um and and and and your your
way of kind of approaching this and
trying to understand it is premised on
on a systems approach like trying to
understand it like a technology or like
code right so walk me through what does
that mean when you say family system
family family systems therapy is um so
if you're working with a acting out kid
for example you assume that that kid
isn't just whatever diagnosis he carries
but that that in some ways he's serving
a function in the family of distracting
or he's trying to protect himself from
something that's happening in the family
MH and that our assumption was we could
reorganize the family and try to improve
whatever relationships were producing
his symptoms and that he would stop
doing that and a lot of times that that
worked but as this family therapist I
was determined to prove that I was in a
department of psychiat and decided to do
an outcome study with eating disorders
because my hero at the time was a guy
named Salvador manucha who had used his
structural family therapy with anorexia
and claimed a lot of success so I was
going to do it with
bulimia and found to my dismay that we
could reorganize the families just right
and still a bunch of my kids didn't
realize they'd been cured and they they
kept going how dare they right so this
is sort of an external family systems
model right organize the people around
the person Afflicted with the condition
you're trying to treat that's right and
and resolve uh with with uh less than
Stellar results is what you're saying
yeah and then out of frustration I began
to ask these kids why are you still
doing it and they started talking this
very weird language to me at the time
talking about these different parts of
them and how they were doing all this
stuff
inside and so you know an example would
be something happens in my life it
triggers this critic who's brutal and
makes me feel horrible and that brings
up a part that feels young and empty and
alone and
worthless and that feeling is so
distressing that then this binge comes
in to get me away from it but the the
binge triggers the critic again who's
calling me a pig on top of the other
names and that goes right to the heart
of that empty worthless young one mhm so
the the beninge has to come back and I
was lucky I had a couple clients who
were extremely articulate about that
whole thing and at first so I didn't
know from Parts at first I thought o
these kids are sicker than I thought
maybe they have multiple personality
disorder and then I listened inside
myself and oh my god I've got them too
and I've got this critic and I can binge
on food sometimes and other things and I
have a piece of worthlessness in there
and so then I calmed down and and got
really curious and just started to ask a
lot of questions about how do they
relate to each other and how does it
work in there and um you know I was
lucky that I hadn't studied any
psychoanalytic or psychodynamic
therapies so I did I came with fresh
eyes right like a beginner's mind mind I
was just going to say that so I really
had to trust what they were saying about
the phenomena
and that's partly why this is different
I think than a lot of things both that
and the systems frame where rather than
just focusing on one part trying to
figure it out I was really trying to
understand the way this whole network
operated as a system and that's what we
go to change we're trying to change the
whole network rather than just one at a
time and my contention is these aren't
just Little Voices or thought patterns
or emotions those are the manifestations
of these parts but if I were to have you
focus on one of them exclusively for a
second and get curious about it and just
ask you find out that it's a full range
personality that really has a lot to
tell you besides the little thought it's
giving you mhm and that it's stuck in an
extreme role often if it's an extreme
part because of something that happened
in your childhood maybe or uh yeah and
that through trial and error over time
we found out how to help all these parts
change into actually leave their extreme
roles and become who they're designed to
be so that's the goal of the
model a lot more still to come but
[Music]
first also returning to the podcast this
year was the wise and gentle rain Wilson
he came on board to wax and Wayne
philosophically on the positives and the
negatives of religious belief how to
build a movement of change and why
spirituality is a
necessity we threw the spiritual baby
out with the religious
bathat so in in our kind of especially
secular left Urban contemporary America
we have rejected anything and everything
having to do with religion for a very
good reason for a very very good reason
let me underline that for a very good
reasons religions have brought some of
the worst pain and suffering and
grotesque aspects of human nature to
Bear over the last couple thousands of
years that you could ever possibly
imagine and every decade you read about
some new horror that you know the
Catholic church or that evangelicals
have engendered but I do think that
there we are missing something by
throwing out religion categorically
we're missing some things that religion
gives us which is purpose meaning
community and a sense of the
Transcendent the sense that there is
something more to strive for there's a
lot more to the very best of religion
and I try and I have a chapter on kind
of the universals of religious faiths
why Buddhism and Islam and and
Christianity are why and how they're
connected the essential ideas that bind
them together and you even have a
chapter called hey kids let's invent a
new religion where I'm like let's let's
take the very best that religion has
brought Humanity over the last three or
4 thousand years let's take the best
ideas from that put it together in a
jambalaya and make our new religion
because we which you call Soul boom I
call it Soul boom
trademark um but I also refuse
categorically to be any kind of Guru or
leader of the Soul boom religion but I I
posit it kind of jokingly but at the
same time there are some by throwing out
religion and we see this current Mental
Health crisis and if you have you have
you read the work of Dr Lisa Miller uh
the awakened brain yeah I had her on the
podcast oh great okay she's amazing
sorry I missed that one yeah I love that
come on
me she's great but there's hard data
that supports how spirituality and
religion
itself makes people happier greater
well-being Greater Community uh more
resilient uh which you know resilience
is one of the big factors in the Mental
Health crisis so it's something to be
explored you know and I can already hear
all the people right now switching off
the podcast and like throwing things
across the room [__] that I'll never be
a part of religion that's so evil and
it's like I get it I get it it has been
it's true but there are some Universal
beautiful truths in religious practice
and let me say
this spirituality there has to be some
kind of systemic sensibility to
spirituality if we want to achieve
social transformation if we want that
Star Trek World there has to be some
kind of systematic practice that leads
in that direction so that's how I would
say different that the bigh faith offers
some again I'm not trying to like
convert people but the the what I love
about the beahive faith is that there
are it it Fosters Grassroots Community
spiritual movements in a systematic way
and I think sorry go ahead people
Gathering to pray together bringing
diverse people together being of service
together uh Children and Youth classes
that are F that are focused on spiritual
virtues Divine virtues you know the the
very best kind of character and
Leadership qualities that Humanity has
to to offer these are ways of building a
Grassroots Community movement that but
you don't have to be a bigh to partake
in this but some kind of systematization
other than a like you say bespoke
spirituality I think is crucial to move
forward sure why you think it's
worthwhile and meaningful for somebody
to
cultivate um a spiritual connection or
to to Really grapple with you know these
ideas that that kind of transcend the
the you know Material World in which you
know kind of predominates our our our
daily experience for somebody who's
listening to this or watching it for
whom maybe they have a negative uh
reaction to religion because of the way
they were brought up or they have an
allergy to anything
spiritual um you know make the case for
why this is worthwhile for somebody to
kind of mine or explore gladly thank you
you great
question so the first thing I will say
is the reason why spirituality is
important is because it is
reality so what is reality I am fully in
agreement with tar shardan who said we
are not human beings having a spiritual
experience we Are Spiritual Beings
having a human experience I fully know
uh goes beyond belief I fully know that
I am a soul and that I am inhabiting or
attached to or in connection with a
bodily form for who knows how long 60 70
90 years I'm not sure how long it'll
last and that is my reality and the who
I am and what I am is not my body it's
not even my personality it's not even
like the background that I you know it's
not the trauma I suffered it's not what
I've been through that there is a little
spark of the Divine inside of me or that
is part of me that is reflecting the
Majesty of the Divine of God the divine
presence the creative Force just like a
sunflower turns to the Sun and follows
the sun throughout the course of the day
that is reality so for me to deny my
reality is is not beneficial to anyone
and at least least I'm not myself so now
if you are a hardcore atheist
and you're like that's [__] prove it
to me uh prove to me this Divine spark
of which you speak I want to see it in a
laboratory or in an algorithm or on a
computer screen well that's not quite
how it works because every spiritual
tradition will show you that we live in
a matrix that we live in a an illusion
and when we wake up from this Corporal
form we are going to be in some greater
reality and this is this has come from
the atheists this idea that you know
perhaps we this we're living in an
avatar simac the simulacrum you know and
uh we're living in a fleshy Avatar and
we're going to wake up to some greater
reality but putting all that aside I
would say for to the atheist or agnostic
that try it and see if your life is
better because there is hard uh we
talked about Dr Lisa Miller and her work
there's hard data that shows around
mental health and well-being that having
um Serenity meaning purpose focus a
sense of service to other others a
losing of oneself to a Transcendent self
of the Divine the Transcendent the
abundance that's around us increases
greatly the quality of Our Lives when we
see ourselves in true humility with the
size and scope of the universe and
whatever infinite universes are Beyond
this universe that it makes the quality
of your life better so cost benefit
analysis putting in a small amount of
time every day I'm talking about 40
minutes in your day to some kind of
spiritual um opening uh and and or
practice has incredible benefits this
has been found time and time again it's
found in the 12-step programs it's found
in Buddhist Meditation it's found in the
most ancient texts that Humanity has
ever proved uh created the the vas and
aads from you know 3,000 years ago this
sense that we are uh a wave on the sea
of creation and the wave crests and the
wave Falls we're a part of something
much greater and much more beautiful
than ourselves and in living in that
state can greatly enrich your life how
was that
boom next up is one of the greatest
music producers of all time founder of
De Jam records and a former president of
Columbia Records Rick Ruben Rick shared
is deeply spiritual approach to Artistry
one that is gloriously explored and his
deeply impactful book the creative act
here is a slice of that
exchange for me the the success happens
when we sign off on a finished thing and
say okay send it out into the world
that's the moment of success and once
that happens I don't back onto the next
um
because that's the only part I have any
participation in that's the only part I
can control everything else is based on
market conditions on Stars lining on one
of Theo one of the stories uh one of the
stories we heard today in what we were
doing was uh all of the people many of
the people whose music came out on
9/11 their music got lost and their
careers never recovered just because
because it happened to come out on
9911 and it's fascinating and that's out
of everyone's control that's again it's
a it's Universal intervention we don't
know how it works but these are all um
one of the things we talk about in the
book is watching these
occurrences sometimes they're good
sometimes they're bad and thinking of it
as riding a wave and that these universe
is pushing us in a direction and we can
ride with that energy and like when
you're surfing if you really try to
fight the wave it's probably not going
to work you know we we try to use the
power of the wave where we're almost
dancing with the wave not not against
the wave and um that's that's the work
of creativity as well certain certain
projects come together very easily and
they happen quickly and they have a
momentum to them and others others are a
real fight
and sometimes we fight that fight and
other times we decide is there is there
another a path of less resistance around
this is there a better way in let's
rethink well if it's so
hard something's up not supposed to be
so hard again it's it's wildly timec
consuming takes a great deal of focus
takes
patience but if there are no signs that
something's working at for a long
time that might be a time to step back
step away there's so much packed into
what you just said I mean first off it
being very
counterintuitive or you know opposite to
this notion that if you want to be
successful you just you push you hustle
you force things thing you force things
into existence in the book you say the
work is the work right what is the work
the work is lots of things the work is
hard but it's play it's about um sharing
and it's about passion it's about
structure of course like it's very
Elusive and it is ephemeral so it's
understandable you're like I don't know
what it is yeah but I know what it's not
yes and and I don't know how to do it
that's another thing like before you
start any new project I always have a
lot of anxiety because I have no idea
what's going to happen now I have a lot
of uh experience that helps now but that
doesn't make it
happen um it takes a tremendous amount
of patience to wait for it to reveal
itself and I guess now I have the wisdom
to know this that that be patient and I
have the discipline to stay with it for
a long time and I I want to make that
point because we were just talking about
sometimes you have to bail
but
the if you if you when while you're in
it for a long time there are usually
Clues they're usually and it might be a
radical course change you could start
out you have a moment Something
Beautiful happens you think up this is
what it's going to be and you start
running in that direction and then you
realize we're going in the wrong
direction right and then you have to you
know set a new course be nimble enough
to not to be able to walk away from that
even when you've invested you know some
ungodly amount of time and effort into
that direction that's not functioning
ABS it's something that we see often is
the um the initial moment when an idea
Springs forth that first sketch the
first demo the first very first rough
often has some um energetic charge in it
that's really compelling and we hear
many stories in in music
where records come out and people don't
uh respond and then they go back to oh
well but it was we missed it it was all
in the demo you know we the the record
screwed up and
um being aware of that's helpful because
you can just because you put more time
in like from the time you've make the
demo you may put in let's say we'd work
for a month after we've made a demo we
work on something for a month might work
on a song for a month we might realize
at the end of that month if we listen
back which is the key always checking
back see I know we're putting time but
are we progressing right is it is it
different or is it better right just cuz
you're working on it a lot doesn't mean
that it's better and after hearing it
you know 10,000 times you're so close to
it and you and and you become like sort
of immune to its Allure and you think
there's something wrong with it and so
you tinker and then you actually end up
dismantling the whole thing it's true
yeah many just get overdone
um so in in the cases when the demo is
the best
version luckily we recognize it and that
ends up being the version now you know
that but it takes discipline confidence
and experience to recognize that the
original GarageBand version of it is
actually better than the highly polished
studio version yes and even if it has
mistakes sometimes you fix sometimes you
hear mistakes you fix the mistakes and
it's not as good right you you wouldn't
expect that it's it's drained of its
energy it's drain of humanity yeah it's
and we don't know this is the other part
we don't know why it's good you you you
hear it there's no there are no metrics
for this the idea that one one person
says uh my my art is better than your
art it's it's an insane idea it's like
they're all it's always apples and
oranges it's like saying my diary entry
is better than your diary entry it's
insane it's the things we make are are
uh a reflection of who we are in this
moment and that's all it is it's not
more than that it can go on and mean
more than that but that's not in our
control so that's not the reason to do
it no and it's something that cripples
artists thinking I have to make the
greatest thing ever made to humankind
and then they uh basically psych
themselves out of being able to make
something good that they they give into
the pressure of thinking it's more than
it is um so one of the things we talk
about in the book is lowering the stakes
where we're not setting out to make the
greatest album of all time we're not
setting out to make the greatest song of
all time we're there to have fun in the
studio we're going to entertain each
other we're going to see if something
happens that's interesting to us and
there's no better
um I found found luckily over the course
of my life that the things that I truly
believe in that that really feel like
something to me other people resonate
with I don't know if that's the case for
everybody but I don't know of a better
metric to use for anyone than I really
feel this if I really feel it it's much
better than I think someone else might
like this it's not really from you know
it's not really me but I think someone
else might like it that's it's a losing
game the audience comes last in service
to the audience the audience wants the
best
thing they don't get the best thing
while you're trying to service them they
get the best thing when you're servicing
yourself beneath countless problems in
our society lies this sleeping giant
which is this profound disconnect that
we have with nature so here to remind us
of the important links between human
biology on the one hand and planetary
biology on the other is none other than
my friend Dr Zack Bush who joined us for
his I don't know umth appearance on the
podcast back in episode
751 I want to maybe come back to that
thought of you know some of these
Technologies are good and doing things I
I think we can't actually make any real
honest or accurate judgment on any of
our Technologies being good or bad until
maybe a few more Thousand Years goes by
and we have different perspective
because there's so many unintended
consequences of human engineering that
is outside of
biology we and and it's it's scary for
me to think that that we're making
judgments on that's a good technology or
bad technology is AI a bad technology I
don't know we'll find out I mean human
Innovation is the story of unintended
consequences it's the story intens and
consequences that are born out of a
fundamental disconnect from nature at
its beginning well and and also a
huus yeah obviously the hubris is the
result of the ego that steps in to
protect the individual that thought it
got rejected right and so our original
wound was Rejection it was we all have
an abandonment disorder at our root and
then we developed an egoic mind and you
know social behavior to try to staunch
the fear guilt and shame cycles that
happen once you're in that abandonment
disorder that keeps us addicted uh great
work on addiction that I'm fascinated by
is um TJ Woodward's work around
conscious recovery and he's really good
at helping people get down to this route
of Abandonment disorders the reason they
have addiction to anything oh I've never
heard of him that's fascinating would
love to have him on B he's got not only
books he's got an incredible curiculum
that kind of comes alongside AA as like
a much more robust look at kind of what
is the root cause and then what is your
relationship back towards addictive
substances and he changes the Paradigm
completely you know to really look at uh
substance abuse as a genius you know
tool for survival of a species that's in
this you know deep abandonment disorder
for an individual that's in deep
abandonment disorder from their parents
that rejected them the father that abuse
them whatever it is and so it's a
beautiful model of again fractals of
what we've done to Nature down at the
individual level but what you see when
you're working true TJ Woodward's work
is oh my God this is the whole Human
Condition we're all addicted to
something and right now a lot of us are
addicted to our biohacking data and so
we are so addictive because we have this
fundamental abandonment disorder way
Upstream what I love about this
Simplicity is is then rethinking the
word
technology uh we think of Technologies
of things that we can that build that
are not of nature that's our current con
concept of technology which discards the
possibility that a human cell with
trillions of atoms that have
self-organized into this thing is not a
technology that diminishes the
possibility that my 14 quadrillion
mitochondria are not Technologies living
inside of myself I believe we are the
greatest technology expressed by Nature
so far this human body is the greatest
technology that's been made by Nature
this far I have a high degree of
confidence of that my trust in that
supersedes anything that I can make that
looks outside of
nature we've defined nature that way
even if you go to the Oxford English
Dictionary nature is defined as
everything on the planet minerals plants
animals everything except humans or
things humans have
made really not only wrote ourselves
outes encapsulate humans as part of
nature which is a perfect encapsulation
of the problem the dualistic nature of
Humanity yeah like like contemplates our
role so what if the greatest technology
ever made is is this human
body what is it capable of doing to to
shift from victim perpetrator into this
true creative state where it can create
universes what is there an opportunity
for me to tap into something so much
deeper than my five senses or my two
hands could ever create because I am a
generative Center and if I can think it
it's occurring somewhere in the
Multiverse if I can imagine it it's
occurring somewhere out there and
there's a lot of people that believe
that's true from indigenous peoples all
the way through if you've dreamed it
it's happening somewhere right now in
the
Multiverse how would I possibly get
there how would I get to this place
where I switch from victim perpetrator
on a daily basis to true
creator and of all places that you know
maybe shoved a huge sign post in my face
on this it was the course of Miracles
there's this extraordinary description
in there of how humans have become
addicted to human relationship in the
effort to complete ourselves we see
something different than ourselves we
feel incomplete and we figure oh that's
the other half if we put that together
then then I'll be whole MH and we become
codependent in those relationships so
that's defined in that space as special
relationship the beauty that is the
opposite of that that is this promise
that kind of sits there is that at some
point in the near future
two human beings could come together
that have completed themselves no longer
looking outside of themselves to realize
that they are a complete technology they
are a complete being they have all that
was ever intended at the highest
technological level of Nature's whole
expression right within themselves and
it says that when those two people saw
each other for the first time they would
truly be seen because in the split state
of the egoic mind that's protecting
ourselves from this addictive
abandonment disorder we can only see see
a mirror of ourselves so as much as I
love you as much as I can talk to you
about all of your incredible attributes
every time I look at you I'm only either
seeing the best of me or the worst of
me and that is the result of this Schism
this split psychology of the egoic mind
which is too afraid to see you
ultimately for the the incredible nature
that you really are and so we protect
ourselves Behind these egoic shields so
that we cannot be seen and we cannot
see when we stop with the addiction to
the outside world through our
relationships through our things and we
become whole for a split second if two
would see each other the amount of love
and awe and just magnanimous sense of
just amazement and wonderment that would
come out of that moment would send
Ripple effects to the whole energies of
the planet and through the species and
we will make our Paradigm leap and so it
just takes two people to finally see
each other to be that next technology of
humanity is what we're told in that
incredible course so is that possible
that we will let go down that egoic
Shield long enough and heal our deep
abandonment disorder to become whole
enough for a moment that this observer
effect that we talked about earlier that
if we really see the universe for all
its beauty it will switch completely
every atom will change we only have to
do that to one other human only see one
other human completely and that observer
effect will change everything I
believe next up is Senator Corey Booker
a truly remarkable person who is
dedicated not only his career but his
life to fighting for social justice
fighting for civil rights and also
Environmental Protection my conversation
with Corey centered on a topic that is
near and dear to both our hearts food
policy reform here's a look into our
fractured food system and what we can do
to fix
it we are a country in in a Health
crisis that that we're not speaking
about we are the wealthiest country on
in the world
but we have some of the highest rates of
diet related diseases that are
mushrooming in cost and just handful of
years or like five our diabet are
spending on uh diabetes has gone up 25%
half our population now is diabetic or
pre-diabetic but it's not just diabetes
it's uh Alzheimer's heart disease stro
strokes and so one out of every $3 in
our government right now is being spent
on Healthcare close cl to one out of
five of our dollars in our economy and I
you know ran for president where the
debate people wanted to have was how do
you provide health care but it's almost
like saying it's like well how do you
mop up the floor when the water is for
us has never turned off we talk about
why we need so much Healthcare yes if so
80% of that spending is for diet related
diseases and I'm all for freedom I want
I want this country eat what you want
but we have designed a system in which
the things that we tell you not to eat
are being subst ided and the things we
tell you to eat we don't subsidize at
all so when my kids walk into a bodega
in Newark they can get a twinky likee
product cheaper than an apple because we
as a society have said we're going to
subsidize everything in that twinky like
product and not the Apple in fact fruits
and vegetables get about 7% of our a
subsidies while the commodity crops that
go to the the the corn syrup and the
things that again are are that are not
making us healthy or to feed animals get
the most of our subsidies and everybody
on this along the the chain is getting
hurt farmers are getting hurt right now
their suicide rates I think are two or
three times higher than the average
American the independent family farmer
is being eviscerated people are losing
their farms in utter numbers again it's
a massive corporate consolidation small
amounts of company are controlling our
food system and they're benefiting from
a policies designed in the 1950s by
people who thought let's just make
calories readily available and that are
can stay on shelves forever when we know
a lot better about nutrition now this
food system that we have is being done
in a way that is all about those
commodity crops which now are being D
doused with chemicals that we don't
fully know what do does to our bodies
but you and I both have
[Music]
glyphosat-prozess quality of our soil so
farmers are losing the ecology is losing
climate change is one of our biggest
contributors to the problem all these
climate activists seem to always forget
that our food system is one of the major
contributors to that um Farmers could be
leading us out of that with us
incentivizing them to do farming
practices cover crops and other things
that preserve uh um soil nutrient-rich
soil biodiverse soil as opposed to the
dirt that's created when you stouse it
in glyphosate so it's a climate change
issue it's ecology issue it's about our
Farmers but it's also about our food
workers people who work in our food
system first of all overwhelmingly
undocumented immigrants from our our our
Farms they're picking most of the food
we eat even to our slaughter houses
which are more corpor concentrated than
during the time of uh uh up in St
Clair's the jungle so you go all the way
to the end users as a guy that you know
Ron Finley says that uh in South Central
we he says South Central we got drive by
and drive-throughs and the
drive-throughs are killing more people
than than the drive buys the number one
killer of African-Americans is Diet
related diseases so this food system is
so broken it's hurting us in every
single way from the farmers who are
producing our food who now get 14 cents
on the dollar of every consumer dollar
spent um because of again massive
corporate concentration all the way down
to very very sick population and so I
think we as a society no matter you're
right or left I told you about the
Cattlemen who were getting hurt by the
system all the way to the people in
communities like mine we need to begin
to expand Consciousness about that this
is not a fat complete that this system
is by Design producing the results that
we're seeing where pharmaceutical
companies are making incredible profits
where literally I I was shocked when I
saw this that a major Health
Organization says well obesity and
children is such a bad thing we we are
advising them to have their stomachs
stapled um um so we have created a
system where people are profiting off of
it but the rest of us all are are losing
and we can redesign it so farmers Thrive
and consumers thrive in health uh
because we know as you've said it many
times on your show food is medicine I
can show you study after study that for
taxpayers if you're fiscally
conservative what a return on on
investment if you make fresh fruits and
vegetables accessible for people with
diabetes or hypertension or the like and
so I want to be a disruptor now I want
to find ways to take the next farm bill
which is coming and see what ways we can
make improvements on it to begin to show
people there's a better way specifically
to the Food Systems issue like how do
you how do you kind of encourage people
to get more involved like are there
certain things that you could you know
advise or recommend people to look into
or how to use their voice specifically
well um every dollar you spend in your
life is a vote um and I'm trying to
think more about everything from where
my clothing comes from to where my food
comes from and if if you have the
flexibility to make
choices you can endorse a lot of good
practices that that are starting and so
what I try to remind myself is that this
is that word you said earlier it is a
practice that trying every day to get up
to live your values is something that's
not hard but
you it is it it demands of us that
whether we stumble we fall we just get
up every day and try our best to live
our light and a life of that it's not a
straight line it takes stumbles you get
hit you get knocked down but getting up
every day and trying to practice
kindness decency and love I think that
that's the highest calling of life
whether you are an elected leader
whether you are a a a a coach or
whatever you have that to me other
people people who live that kind of Life
those are the people that help light my
path like Kevin bats that encourage me
in my
way kind of a pinch me moment the very
talented and very handsome actor writer
and director Zack bra joined me to teach
us about how to understand how to accept
and how to process difficult emotions
through Art here's an excerpt from our
conversation back in episode
744 well the the first impetus for
writing about tragedy and and Trauma was
I lost my my sister had an aneurism in
2016 um and she she actually survived
although in in in not a fully conscious
State and some some tiny percentage of
herself was alive uh for two more
years um and my mom and and brother in
particular were by her bedside almost
every day uh cuz they were lived up
north and I would go visit her and she
was not um only a fraction of herself
was there um then she eventually uh
passed and um soon after my father who
was 84 but uh I can't help but think
that it it it kind of expedited his
demise he he died of cancer um
after I went into the covid still
grieving all of these
things and then my best friend was
living in my guest house he and his wife
and their newborn baby were uh searching
La for for a home they found a home they
went back to New York uh to collect
their things and literally like the
first day of lockdown
um uh they were they came back from New
York and he had contracted covid and
this was at the very beginning right
early early nobody knew what the hell
you know was the Mayhem of the beginning
of I think March was of 2020 right uh
he's 41 years old very healthy a
Broadway star um trying to get his life
going as a TV and film actor and um and
he was very sick and they put him on a
ventilator and he never came off of it
so Not only was I on the front lines of
losing someone who was close to me to
covid but his wife and baby were living
in on my on my property in the guest
house you know trying to digest this
this horrible thing and and and it was
it was so traumatic because we we didn't
know if she had Co or we didn't know you
know it was so mean now was back when
we're all like sort of spraying our
groceries in the front lawn and all that
kind of craziness before there was a lot
of fear she'd be sobbing in the in in a
pile on the on the ground and we and we
were like can we hug her is it safe to
hug her she she might have been exposed
to it so it was really really uh
horrific and it in in that head space uh
during the lockdown that I I sat down to
write this film um about grief and about
loss but also about
how how how one stands back up after
after such things MH i' i' I've really
just been battling um I battled
depression and anxiety my whole life and
I I I had OCD pretty bad as a child and
um I think I found writing and
Performing as a way of um
of dealing with that particularly humor
um um making people laugh was a high for
me I didn't play sports at all I had no
I had no connection to sports I didn't
know how to make friends so I became
because I was a funny kid I became a
Class Clown and that's how I made
friends MH and then when I was around 13
years old my you know I lived in the
east coast in Jersey and sleepwe Camp
was very popular and um a lot of the
kids would go to a traditional sleep
away camp that was about sports and I I
didn't I didn't shine and and I felt
alienated and I was like what's wrong
with me I love performing and my my
parents found this theater camp for me
that was called Stage Door Manor and I
went there and it was like epiphanous it
was Utopia it was a it was a place where
everyone was a performer and everyone
was like me and I didn't know that there
were other kids that many kids out there
like me mhm so just from an early age
the way I would manage anxiety and and
depression um was um creating art
whether it was as a performer or as a or
as a writer um I have a very early
memory of of being in fifth grade and
and the teacher said who's going to we
had to write an essay and who's going to
get up in front of the class and and
read their essay and I did and I had
written other kids in the class into the
essay and made a very funny essay but
the the protagonist were kids in the
class and I got up there and they were
belly laughing as I read it and I
remember clocking the teacher in the
back of the classroom holding her
stomach and laughing and I thought this
is probably the highest high I've had in
my life so far yeah so is this is there
any chance this is a career when's
career day um so that's a long-winded
way of saying um that's why I became a
writer and a filmmaker was a way
of um was a way of find trying to find
shared um Community with these feelings
that I have and the answer your other
question about is is it cathartic it's
most cathartic when I finally watch it
with an audience and I see their
reaction when they laugh at the right
moment when they swipe a tear at the
right moment when their pin drop silent
at the right moment that's when I feel
like oh I'm not alone in these emotions
it's an antidote to loneliness like
these emotions that I'm feeling are are
collective absolutely absolutely that's
the best that's that's better said than
I could have said it it's an antidote to
loneliness I think it was the way I was
processing all of these things but I
didn't want to write specifically the
story of of my life I didn't want to
write about covid I didn't want to write
about my sister's aneurysm right but all
of that
was you know it's like as a writer I'm
sure you know and and other writers can
relate you you have all of this this is
what's gurgling inside of you and when
you sit down and stare at the blank
cursor to see what's going to come out
or a songwriter I imagine would be the
same this is what came out this story is
it was sort of my interpretation of all
these feelings I had including um
recovery and and and things I'm
wrestling with with with my own
relationship ship to to alcohol and um
all all of that stuff became um became a
part of it um but it's but it's by no
means directly um my story MH uh writing
is sitting alone at a blinking curser
telling yourself you
suck um it's hard that's what I would
tell people I I I won't be as um try and
scare anyone away from it um but know
that it's that I'm this deep into it and
I battle procrastination I battle
working so I would say develop very
early on I mean you've had some of these
amazing people on your podcast the
what's the name of the the guy who wrote
War of art Stephen pressfield yeah
Stephen pressfield and and um and the
like um you know you have to develop a
system very early on something I never
did that that is failsafe for you
working and producing content and that
is in in 2023 that is very much turning
off your Wi-Fi and getting your phone
out of the room um there are so many
distractions um and then I believe with
with with Mr pressfield it's about
putting your butt in the chair and not
being afraid to not know what it is
today but getting in the chair and
showing up
mhm um but it's it's it's like running
with an elephant on your back if you're
if you're trying to do it with your
phone in your
[Music]
hand renowned futurist thought leader
co-founder of Wired Magazine who am I
talking about I'm talking about Kevin
Kelly who came on the podcast and just
dropped wisdom gold on so many subjects
we talked about careers relationships
parenting finances Innovation basically
excellent advice for living which also
happens to be the title of his latest
book here's a look into that
conversation
it's it's really clear right now that
the major engine of wealth and I would
also uh suest personal happiness is is
um being able to think different that's
that's the engine and when we're when
we're all connected 24 hours a day
around the world with our little
devices the the true value is being able
to think a little differently that's the
source of innovation that's how you make
great things that's how you make great
art and um anything that can help you
think differently including AI which
we'll talk about later I'm sure but
travel and other
experiences doing having uh reading
different books than other people read I
mean there's lots of ways to do that but
you want to really cultivate that
ability to think differently in a world
where everybody's connected together all
the time and so I I I would argue yes
um Zig while everybody's zagging you
know and um try and do something
different and you know travel is a
tremendously efficient and productive
and inexpensive way to do that and um
taking time off goofing off is another
great way to do that sabatical Sabbath
um is another great way so
there's that's the assignment really for
most people is is to have different
ideas to approach things differently
you're going to need help doing that and
my kids sort of have heard many times
but very I know every couple years I sit
them down I have three kids and I say um
I have a magic wand and I'm going to
give you a billion
dollars but only if you tell me what
you're going to do with it right you
what are you going to do with a billion
dollars and they'll go through the kind
of lists and maybe they're imagining
they're young adults and stuff you know
I would maybe buy a house or something
and I would go on a trip somewhere and I
would have this I said okay um that you
haven't built you haven't spent any of
your money yet right cu
in six months that will Tye interest
will pay back and you're back with a
billion dollars now what are you going
to do oh well maybe I I'm making
something up maybe I'll start a little
shop selling um knitwear or I want to do
a little um dayare Center or whatever it
is and it's like okay you don't need a
billion dollars for
that so this idea I mean most people's
dreams are not a matter of they're not
gated by money they're gated by
other things and um it's very clear in
my own experiences that that that dream
of wanting to work to have the fortune
to do what it is is is that's a really
convoluted and unnecessary way around of
getting what you want your dreams to do
I so so I've concluded this is not in my
advice book but this is a piece of
advice I have now which is my advice is
if you can all help it do not earn a
billion dollars okay
please do me a favor I'll try to avoid
that do yeah exactly you'll be much do
not earn a billion dollars well the real
calculus is is the money that you're
earning creating freedom for you or is
it creating you know a a more you know
calcified prison for yourself ex right
because it can do either of those things
I'm sure there are billionaires who've
been able to figure out how to you know
create Freedom out of that for
themselves maybe not I don't know I
don't I don't even know that I know any
billionaires you do but yeah um you know
if your if your wealth can provide that
then okay yeah but if it's just creating
misery for yourself then what's the
point right and so that that level of
getting what you need comes way before a
billion dollars is is what I'm saying
it's like you know and so at that point
of a billion dollars it is a burden it
is something that really weighs on the
people who have it it's kind of like
Fame it's my advice which is you really
don't want to be famous either if you
just read any biography about a famous
really famous person it's another type
of imprisonment and uh most of the
people who are really really famous
really regret that that is because they
have to deal with it all the time and
it's a it's a real um what's the word
kind uh hinders it hinders them in many
ways and so it's not Freedom at all and
I and it's the same thing so so um you
really want to focus on this is my piece
my favorite piece of advice from the
book which is don't aim to be the
best aim to be the only right and that
only is where you'll you'll be much more
um satisfied happy you'll probably have
enough um and and that is that is the
route it's the the billions is another
person's success that's that should not
be your success it's it's it's someone
else's movie If you're trying to make a
billion dollars you want to go you want
to be the star on your own movie sure
but explain that a little bit more
because the idea of being the only is an
intimidating yes Prospect right like how
do you become the only the only at what
and I think becoming the only at
anything even if it's the most obscure
thing on the planet does require again
back to what we were talking about
earlier you know kind of being
contrarian or cutting Against the Grain
and and and doing things a little bit
differently and I I don't know that
every is is sort of cut out for that
yeah so so um first of all it's it is a
high bar it is a very very high bar and
the second thing in my experience in in
both my own life and looking at other
people it will take most of your life to
arrive
there there there might be the really
weird freakish person who's born and has
a clear idea of what they're really
great at that nobody else can do and um
they go for it but most of us it's um
it's a long and mandering winding road
with lots of detours and right turns and
setbacks and turnarounds and everything
else to to arrive there and you actually
don't never arrive you're always on that
journey of trying to figure out what
what it is about yourself that is
special and unique um but but it doesn't
um and okay so so so there is there is a
a paralysis I've seen in young people
it's like I don't know what I'm
passionate about I don't know and so I
can't really start I can't give my 100%
until I know what that is and um I
become
convinced um that the um the proper ways
to start is to master
something and in that Mastery that
becomes a platform that you begin to
kind of move towards discovering what it
is passion is a product of action
exactly it's not the other way around
waiting around until you're struck with
what you're passionate about as a as a
precursor to action is is the way most
people think about it and that just
leads to paralysis and like a protracted
period of confusion exactly so you you
almost and and it doesn't matter where
you start because that's not where
you're going to be ending and that's
true again if you look any remarkable
person that you
admire they didn't start there they
arrived at their and the more kind of
distinctive unique special and only they
are the more likely they started way
away from where they actually discovered
what they were good at and so don't
doesn't really don't be concerned about
where you're starting as long as you're
moving forward in that way of really
deliberately trying to get better you'll
arrive in in your in the right
[Music]
direction fostering your own best work
is one thing but how do you Foster the
best work in others well there's no one
better to answer that question than
Pixar co-founder Ed kall a leader and
also a leadership Authority who shaped
Pixar's supremely Innovative company
culture here are some philosophies he's
leveraged to build effective teams and
why he believes failure is a path to
growth your original motivation into
rethinking management and Leadership and
and on some level the impetus of the
book was trying to figure out why great
companies when they reach a certain
level of scale suddenly no longer are
great right for me it's a it's a
fascinating thing because I see it just
happened in company after company is
what is actually going on what are
people thinking the one of the
difficulties that companies have is that
because of underlying changes that take
place in this in particularly it's true
with computer related companies but now
it's happening everywhere is there are
fundamental changes that are taking
place uh not only in the technology but
in its applications and now because of
the use of uh more computers and and and
cell phones and the whole web system of
of transfering information but also
societal changes and environmental
changes uh a lot of things are happening
pretty rapidly and people have
difficulty conce conceiving of what it
means to change their business plan mhm
let alone other things they need to do
in their lives mhm but it's very hard
for them to conceive of it and Steve was
unusual in that his focus on is was on
what is the right thing to do when uh he
they were working on the uh the
iPhone but when it was secret yeah so we
went up to the secret lab to see it and
what he said was we're reaching the
point where there isn't really any you
know a lot more growth both in the
laptop computers or including the uh the
portable computers so we're going to
need to have a different business model
going forward now that in
itself is very unusual right so that's
one thing that I found interesting just
okay that sort of sets them apart from
other people the underlying thing Steve
did understand was that you have to find
out what the truth is and and adapt to
it if something wasn't right he would
switch you commit to something with
passion and when you're wrong you change
and that that's hard for people to hold
on to their head because you think if
I'm committed that I'm committed I'm not
going to listen to things that's going
to change my course because I'm
committed to the course but if I'm not
committed then I change course too
easily so what does it mean to to both
be committed and at the same time say oh
oh um I've just realized I'm wrong we're
going to change that's very
hard and I'd say the best leaders and
the best filmmakers that's what they do
we're GNA go down this path okay it's
not working we're going to change yeah
so how do you be how do you uh do both
at the same time and it is
possible um but that's when the you I
think that's when the best stuff happens
yeah well the way that it's possible is
through these many kind of systems and
philosophies that you end up
implementing at Pixar that creates this
unbelievable run of extraordinary movies
over the tenure of of your leadership
there the overarching idea here is how
do we get the most compelling Innovative
creative work out of this group of
people and what is the environment that
we need to cultivate in order to
facilitate that and you know the
opportunity to fail and fail fast uh can
be part of the you know the environment
to make something new and better and
different actually we don't use the term
failure very much inside of
Pixar um now we do if we actually have
something fails we say that it fails
we're not trying to avoid it but the
word's too
loaded um because uh you know starting a
school if you fa in a class then that's
a bad thing because it means you weren't
smart enough or you didn't work hard
enough um but also when you get out and
bridges fail uh relationships fail so
there's a real and pable Aura of danger
around failure while we also would say
that we've learned a lot from our
failers because we have we all recognize
that is that meaning of failure is
actually sort of overridden by the
danger part of failure if we recognize
that then say well okay there are a lot
of times when we should be using a
somewhat different terminology which is
that we're trying to make something work
let's try this though that didn't work
let's try this we don't need to overload
it so I try to be very careful about the
words and how they're used it's like I
think it should be used for things which
are uh where you really do have a a
major problem and the other one is
people get stuck for different
reasons we all do this you're trying to
work on something Bang Your Head on the
wall and I remember this you know from
like just doing homework or Mak in
school right yeah sometimes you're
trying to do it you got to do it you got
to
schedule my I'm sorry my brain is fried
I'm
stuck well I for me the big step is is
that when you see that there's a problem
you have to ask what
and and you it isn't one of those things
that you can force on them you say you
need to do this you need to fix it this
way which is a natural thing for people
to do I think it's the right thing to do
though it's like okay this isn't going
the way I would hope it it's going why
isn't it going this way what's getting
in their way and what can I do to solve
the thing that's getting in their way
because they may not see it and if they
don't see it and I'm not paying
attention then we all miss
mhm and then it still it sits there and
it festers and it affects people but we
can
ask and and figure out what actually
happened why did it happen and what what
can we do about
it I think we can all agree that our
media landscape is rapidly changing it's
shifting it's always evolving and in a
world inundated with so much new
technology the growth of artificial
intelligence and the power of social Med
media where is our shared Humanity well
Emy nominated writer comedian and
cultural critic baratunde thirston
joined me to talk about all of this the
impact of technology and social media on
society and the current Perils of our
democratic
[Music]
system you know where are we in the
world of media right now how do you make
sense of it um with great difficulty
it's we're in a a tech tonic shift like
like the tectonic word and everything's
changing really really rapidly you know
I I'm 45 years old I was born in 77
Washington DC my mom was a computer
programmer for the federal government
and so I I had a computer in my
household for longer than most people my
age regardless of the economic and
racial situation I came out of which
made it even more rare and so it's
always been an enabler it's been fun uh
and it's been this connective tool and
so we got the internet cool everybody
gets a voice and they like oh we got the
internet man everybody gets a voice and
and things that used to be hard for
organizing and amplifying are easy and
that that can be great for Trans kids
it's also great for like white
supremacist organizers too and there's
no like Morality In that so with the
speed of of like what I see with media
now is a bunch of stuff I think of its
role as being this mirror that reflects
us back to us and helps tell us who we
are and who we're capable of and that's
where my frustration is greatest because
I think we're getting a very narrow
reflection of ourselves back to
ourselves and what these tools are
capable of is beautiful but what we're
actually using them for is a vast subset
of that beauty and so we get like ad-
driven monetization of stuff we get uh a
hyperfocus on conflict and Discord
versus collaboration and creativity uh
we get subservience and following versus
kind of ownership and and setting your
own course and we are what we eat and I
think we become what we see uh and and
we become what people tell us we already
are so there's a lot of responsibility
in the media game and technology is just
adding fuel to an already raging fire in
terms of like possibility confusion and
and sometimes uh chaos the acceleration
of change is so massive but truth is
always truth and there's always wisdom
that transcends whatever is happening we
may not be able to relate to the
specific experience of what it's like to
grow up with you know technology X but
there are still you know some some
there's there's an architecture of of
you know how to be in the world that
there's there's something underneath
that superficial reality right whether
it's virtual or physically tangible our
Humanity has some consistency right we
have have an emotional experience we
have desires and needs we have fears we
have a a sense of belonging or it's
opposite a sense of purpose or its
absence and so we have to figure out a
way to to tap into that deeper frequency
if you're trying I mean I remember
telling businesses when I would advise
them on social media strategy you know
don't ask me what your Vine strategy
should be Vine will one day not be here
what's your story right and then you
figure figure out how you're going to
express it in the medium of the moment
mhm we all need to kind of get below the
surface it's increasingly important
because the surface is ever changing and
I don't have a simple answer for that
but I just acknowledge it as a major
contributing challenge to the sense of
rupture and disruption that we're all
facing that part is unprecedented the
yeah the big thing here is you know we
already feel like we're in a posttruth
world but we ain't seen nothing yet but
the under current of humanity is that
truth you know this this this notion
that truth is important right like yeah
we agree on that right I mean you and I
what's true and not true like
understanding the difference between
that is important but I feel like we're
creeping towards a situation where
there's going to be a lot of people who
would rebut that yeah and say actually
truth is not important what's important
is is winning or or you know audience
capture or just making sure that your
narrative is the one that's on top when
you have you know when the Deep fake
technology and all it's like the ability
to obscure truth or tell whatever story
that you want to tell uh in the most
convincing way yeah completely
untethered from anything real or true
you know it becomes it becomes you know
pretty uh apocalyptic we don't just need
a sort of a a competitive system we
don't just need a system in which truth
competes with untruth
we need a system in which the incentives
for truth compete with the incentives
for untruth and and and where we are
where we are now that is not really the
case you know like you can be outlandish
and dishonest and generate the markings
of reward through attention through
likes through money for being untruthful
and the punishments aren't quite aligned
with that either so so the downside
could be turned up and the upside could
be turned down meanwhile
for those of us who love and value truth
we've also got to build a system that
rewards it and and offers demerits for
undermining it we got to be able to to
show
transparently that truth has value and
and I don't want to just sit here and
say yeah the truth is always better like
clearly historically speaking it doesn't
always win because untruths have been
able to attach themselves to things that
people value and ultimately we value
belonging perhaps as an example more
than we value truth we value
self-preservation more than we value
truth genocides are built on lies all of
them they somehow compelled millions of
people to participate actively or
passively in them because they saw
something in it for them
self-preservation belonging lack of
ostracization to to uphold a lie so so
lies had a lot of co-conspirators and
we've got to make sure we rally when
it's so much easier to create and spread
a lie we need the truth to have some
allies and some rewards built in I I
haven't thought about that at all this
is a real time like oh snap what does
that even mean for us but I think if we
ignore or try to
pretend that the truth is just obviously
better we are in for world to hurt cuz
it isn't obvious a lot of times we have
accomplished magic literal Magic from
the perspective of most humans who've
ever lived rockets and all the
technological advances and the wealth
creation so we're capable of so much
more than hiding from the truth and I
just think we need to hear that more we
need someone to Believe in Us and I just
demand that we aced to
them this year one of the greatest
basketball players of all time Grace the
show NBA legend and author of 61 Chris
Paul Chris imparted valuable life
lessons on the importance of
prioritizing consistency falling in love
with the work mentorship and more here's
a slice from episode
[Music]
762 I I think one of the biggest things
is
community right if you look at any
business plan anything that uh tries to
grow it's all about Community right
about sharing with others and finding
that connectivity that we may be from
different backgrounds I mean at the end
of the day that's the premise of my book
my book is about my grandfather but
there's other people who have had
mentors or family members that they were
connected to like that and so the
importance of community and sharing your
experiences with other people and not
necessarily forcing it on people cuz
even like with a plant-based lifestyle
or anything a lot of times people don't
want things forced on them but sometimes
you got to nudge it you know you gotta
keep at least giving them the
information and it may take them a while
to actually try it and um when I think
about change right I I just think about
stacking days stacking days my son is is
small right he's small just like I was
and I've talked to him about the
training and how hard it is and this
that and the third but he's he's finally
starting to see a little bit of change
right in his game or whatever in his
ability and all I keep telling him is
just keep stacking days M just keep
stacking days as long as you keep
stacking days I promise you I promise
you you will see the change
but my coach used to always say
everything that you want is on the other
side of hard right he had another I
think I said in the book he said reps
removed doubt right reps removed doubt
my biggest frustration with my son used
to be we would go outside at the house
and he would shoot a shot and he'd be
mad he'd be like dang I be like what you
mad for you don't get up enough
reps you know so those are the those are
the only things you can control anyway
yep your effort and the consistency of
your effort right there's a quote uh in
the book that I love which is hard work
is my preferred language and I try to
speak it fluently like that's [__]
great yeah you know yeah and just stack
it up that's all you can do and walk
away what is your relationship to
failure also like missing that shot is
it a big deal or are you just moving on
another rep another rep another rep I
was in the gym last night I was telling
you with with the kid um Mercy Mercy
Miller last night um we had to end this
drill we had to end with this drill that
I do where you shoot a three in this
corner and then you run to the other end
of the Court shoot a three in this
corner mhm run to this
corner come to this corner right so
that's four shots then you go to this
Wing five that Wing six this Wing seven
this Wing eight top of the key Nine this
top 10 yeah non-stop so Sprint Sprint
Sprint 10 shots got to make seven out of
10 and we done with the workout for the
day um I went knocked it out whatnot now
Mercy got got to go 10 for 10 I went
eight eight I went eight out of 10
Mercy's Mercy's turned to go first time
he I think he might have got five out of
10 one again didn't get it one again
didn't get it one again didn't get it
kept getting the six out of 10 and he
would have to cuz you had to just make
seven seven out of 10 he get to the last
one missed it he might have did this
drill 10 times 10 times and my son was
there too and I told Chris I said listen
Mercy can work out with me any day cuz
he didn't
complain he didn't do nothing this kid
is about to be a senior in high school
he didn't complain he just kept
breathing I kept talking to him like
don't worry about it just keep keep
going keep going and sure enough after
10 11 tries he got it he got it and I I
appreciated that from him and I told him
at the end of our workout because he was
like man appreciate you letting me come
work I said no thank you cuz you make it
fun for me and that's the fun part about
having 12 kids in NBA having all of
these young kids coming up and training
with them and working out with them
because that's that's the exciting part
for me is to know that when I'm done
playing I'll still be watching and be
like man yeah yeah yeah yeah that's cool
man and I'm sure you know within the NBA
because you're you know more of an elder
Statesman now you have all these young
players who are you know looking up to
you for that kind of guidance and for
you to recognize like that that brings
you Joy you know to kind of get back in
that way I think I think it's cool so uh
any any parting words
for the uh aspiring athlete out there
somebody's trying to tap into a little
bit more Mastery into their life yeah um
I mean you hear all these saying all the
time where they say you only going to
get out of it what you put into it but
um I would say fall in love with the
work right like I always say about the
NBA I've had guys I've had teammates and
it's fine some guys be like I don't
watch basketball when I go home cuz I
play too much I don't know I'd be like
listen you think if somebody work on
work on Wall Street when they go on
vacation they not checking um the stock
exchange you know but to each his own
right
so if you fall in love with the work
aspect of it then the success and the
accolades that come with it but you got
to fall in love with the work don't just
fall in love with the the showers of
people telling you how good and great
you are it like you if you fall in love
with the work aspect of it then every
everything else I promise to fall into
place thanks for going on that ride with
me it really has been such an incredible
year on the podcast I really hope you
enjoyed this look in the rear view links
to all the full episodes and the social
media accounts for all the guests
excerpted today can of course be found
in the show notes as well as on the
episode page at richw world.com part two
with a bunch more awesome excerpted
conversations will be up later in the
week until then stay tuned peace
PL that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. ritual.com
if you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
new newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason camiolo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel cise thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt traper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plant
[Music]
namaste